[Music]  how does one come to know the series  dark secrets  monsters are they real  I want you to tell me what happened tell  me the secret of the Essex I don't  expect a writer to understand mr. Lovell  promise me let's come back come back as  quick as it's almost night I swear  normally a captain gets to choose this  first week an experienced captain yes  centuries before sailors feared sailing  off the edge of the earth  we were headed for the edge of sanity  I believe you have seen things no one  else has seen what is it  you will surely perish out there  we might also survive  those recruit on the  yeah  the living breeze is mine  so it's true yes  too much is true  town beats Pfeiffer  hah flung the harbour Glauber